on va en parler tout de suite avec
daniel kof il est maire honoraire de
langoat bonjour à vous merci d'être avec
nous en direct ce matin sur rtl france
dont vous êtes le maire de la petite
commune de langoat où résident environ
600 habitants chez vous quel est l'état
du système de santé chez nous et de
notre petite commune de l'ombre et nous
sommes proches d'une métropole donc le
métropole rennaise ce qui fait que
l'offre de soins est relativement
importante avec un hôpital beaucoup de
médecins et la situation se dégrade
énormément plu nous allons vers le
centre bretagne ou l'a vraiment à peu
près une quinzaine de communes sont très
loin de tout médecin de tout cabinet
médical de tout pharmacien de toute
offre médicale et que ça pose énormément
de problèmes d'autant plus que dans ces
territoires da il y a un problème de
connexion internet et que les gens du
mal à prendre des rendez vous par
exemple via les réseaux via internet
donc la situation et inégalitaire et
même dans les endroits où tout va pour
le mieux elle est quand même tendu c'est
à dire que nous voyons aujourd'hui des
difficultés même dans notre secteur
avoir un rendez vous nous avons aussi
des difficultés quand il s'agit de la
saison touristique à consulter un
médecin
donc il y a des idées des situations si
vous voulez de fragilité et il ya
autrement des situations très grave de
déserts médicaux dans notre région
bretagne et l état des lieux que vous
faites dans l'hexagone je crois que dans
l'hexagone c'est à peu près la même
situation qu'en bretagne c'est à dire
une grande disparité entre les villes
centres on va dire les métropoles qui
sont plutôt bien dotées de d'offres et
médicales et puis les territoires les
plus ruraux qui veut sont absolument
désertifier et la situation s'aggrave
les inégalités entre les territoires
c'est grave véritablement sur ce sujet
n'a d'ailleurs comme sur bien d'autres
comment vous expliquez cette
désertification
alors d'abord il ya une autre comment
une augmentation du départ en retraite
des médecins qui ont du mal
à trouver des successeurs également les
médecins ne veulent plus travailler seul
aujourd'hui ne même plus ils veulent
travailler plutôt dans des cabinets
médicaux ce qui se comprend avec toute
une offre autour d'eux donc ils sont
plus du tout d'accord de partir dans des
endroits isolés dans lesquelles il
aurait pourtant beaucoup de travail mais
où ils n'auraient pas de relation de
travail avec d'autres collègues
donc nous nous trouvons avec une grande
difficulté à la fois remplacé ses
médecins l'avaient anticipé et c'est ce
que font les communes la plupart du
temps c'est d'essayer de d'anticiper de
regarder quels médecins vont partir à la
retraite et il faut dire aussi que nous
avons l'aide aussi des médecins qui eux
mêmes ont bien conscience qu'ils vont
laisser leur clientèle à leurs patients
sur le bord du chemin et il s'en
préoccupe aussi donc il ya une sorte de
lien entre les communes et les
collectivités et les médecins
aujourd'hui pour trouver pour maintenir
voire crée parfois une offre médicale
alors en 2018
il y avait un plan de lutte contre la
désertification médicale qui a mis
l'accent sur la télémédecine pour
pallier justement à ce problème
est ce que c'est une solution viable
suffisante selon vous non c'est pas du
tout suffisant d'autant plus que la
télémédecine est compliqué dans des
endroits où il ya une désertification
par ailleurs delà de l'internet où on a
des en bretagne dans notre région
bretagne 35 % simplement des des bretons
et les bretonnes sont connectés contre
54 % sur l'ensemble du territoire
français
donc il y a ça ne peut pas fonctionner
et ça fonctionne aussi très très
difficilement pour les personnes
n'excusent âgées qui n'y voit pas là un
outil du taux de facile pour pour leurs
soins sans compter la relation directe
avec le médecin qui est extrêmement
important et beaucoup beaucoup de
pathologies sont quand même détecté dans
le cabinet du médecin est difficilement
par par internet les pouvoirs publics
qu'attendez-vous de leur part et le
bilan de l'action justement pour
éradiquer ce problème de la
désertification médicale je pense que
nous sommes dans une relation si vous
voulez trop dorée de entre l'état
central et les territoires il y à là
c'est le centralisme à la française qui
est bien connu et qui a des effets très
négatifs
donc je pense que nous devrions réussir
mieux si les agences régionales de la
santé qui dépendent aujourd'hui du
ministère à paris dépens des plus tôt
des régions et nos tests régulièrement
de ma région la région bretagne
nous serions beaucoup plus alerte pour
prendre des décisions très
territorialisée et nous associer
véritablement un plan santé publique où
chaque citoyen ne serait pas un moins de
20 minutes à plus de vingt minutes je
n'irai de de toute offre médicale de
qualité
merci beaucoup à vous daniel que je
rappelle que vous êtes maire honoraire
de langouet